welcome back to Las Vegas now in today's
legal minute we are learning the main
three reasons why people can sue a car
dealership Eric Palacios from Eric
Palacios and Associates the sponsors of
this segment tells us more
hi I'm Eric Palacios welcome to the
legal minute the question of the week is
what are the three main reasons people
Sue car dealerships number one false
advertising car dealerships can be sued
for false advertising such as making
false claims about the vehicle's
condition features or warranties number
two lemon law violations dealerships can
also be sued for violating lemon laws
which protect consumers from buying a
vehicle that has ongoing and serious
defects that cannot be repaired
appropriately and number three unfair
business practices dealerships can also
be sued for unfair business practices
such as hidden fees bait and switch
tactics or failing to disclose important
information about the vehicle or
financing options when buying a new or
especially a used car know your rights
and do your research
I'll give Eric Palacios and Associates a
call at
702-44-7777 for more information and we
will be right back